hallo ihr adventskalender liebhaber hier
ist wieder einmal waren und bekommt zu
einem neuen an box ich habe ein
geständnis zu machen und das fällt mir
wirklich nicht gleich wie saks ist
einfach ich bin eines kleinen jungen
frau ich habe noch nie in meinem leben
slime in der hand gehabt und als ich
einen schönen tag in berlin mit meinem
freund timo hatte und wir so durch das
einkaufszentrum liefen stand ich
plötzlich vor müller und dachte mir
mensch ja ja irgendwie gefühlt alles
vielleicht habe es hier auch
adventskalender und lasst mich euch
sagen sie hatten adventskalender
deswegen geht es heute nicht um food
oder beauty wir testen einen slime
adventskalender der style
adventskalender ist von der marke grace
und jetzt alle zusammen dieses videos
nicht gesponsert ich weiß nicht warum
aber ich bin so aufgeregt vor diesem
adventskalender
er hat 19 eur 99 gekostet also ich finde
das ist die bezahlbare preiskategorie
die kinder haben so spaß auf diesem
adventskalender aber was ich mich frage
so sieht der kein bisschen weihnachtlich
aus also das ist lecce linie sommerparty
die sie feiern liebe marke craven ihr
das sieht warum habt ihr euch gegen
einen weihnachtsmotiv entschieden das
würde mich wirklich an dieser stelle
interessieren ist german slime formula
wpa frei und glutenfrei na das ist doch
super klasse ich weiß gar nicht wie man
selber macht ich glaube man braucht
spülmittel und den rest vom rezept
schreibt die kommentare
keine ahnung man wälzt länder auch
packen wir fangen an mit türchen nummer
1 formate slime sein heimleitung gerne
klein neuer farbwechseln das land ist da
spiele mit ihm und staunen wie sich die
farbe für ein land freudig auf die
kommenden tage und die verschiedenen
magix zwei so viele nichten und neffen
ich werde in allen einfach diesen slime
adventskalender holen ist doch perfekt
das ist normal
also dieses klein wechselt seine farbe
warum ist das ein hype ich weiß wie ich
es mag oder hast du wechselst du die
farbe bestimmt körperwärme wie spielt
man mit sein was macht man mit slime
das riecht wer riecht ist also dieser
schleim regel eine tupperdose die ich
das erste mal aufgemacht hat sie auch
eines kleinen jungen frau seit das
gefühl ist das hört sich an als ob da
was dran wer aber noch nicht wann
wechselst du deine farbe ins spiel doch
schon mit dias verändert nicht seine
farbe stadt ist kaputt vielleicht musste
ich den ganzen tag damit spielen dass
sich die farbe verändert aber bis jetzt
verändert sich nichts also packe es
wieder zurück in die packung guide ag
ist eine typische nummer zwei ist groß
ein türchen nummer zwei hier sind so
kleine plastiken nuggets fülle diese
dose nach und nach mit deinen eigenen
magic slim kreation erzeuge tolle
glitzereffekte indem du die
verschiedenen farben miteinander mischt
aber nur ein weg sein
[Musik]
das ist ein toller 2 wir packen jetzt
mal einmal die ganze bühne da rein
das ist ein tolles erlebnis wird alle
daraus gefallen und mal mit den sitzen
reißen
wir haben das jetzt unseres kleinen
perlen mischungen was machen wir damit
ich stecke sagen wir mal meinen finger
nach nimmt mein schwein das überhaupt
auf ich hab das gefühl das verbindet
sich gar nicht er zieht sich das
bestimmt richtig cool an mit den perlen
drin so verwirrt von diesem zeug also
dass es jetzt nicht meine
lieblingsbeschäftigung die perlen
verbinden sich nicht gut mit dem was
wird wohl in typische nummer drei drin
sein silberner schleim und
geheimnisvolle perlen kreiere deinen
einen magic slim mit kohle metallic look
ja jetzt ist ekelig nicht mehr das
portal 2 mit metallic look echt voll
metalle schon mal wieder gesehen wir
diesen perlen
warum verstört mich alles was ich gerade
tue
[Musik]
zerstören so richtig verbinden will sich
das aber nicht mehr
es fällt auch die ganze zeit ab diese
kügelchen dieser slime ist wirklich sein
geld wert
4 was kannst du mit deinen eigenen magix
islam sorten mit dieser farbe mischen
die farben vorsichtig in kleinen mengen
das gewünschte ergebnis gerechnet nicht
verraten das ist auch giftig nur noch
eine farbe das ist pink metallic kommen
wir zu nikolaus bittet um das spiel das
an nikolaus es gibt was cooles zu
nikolaus ob gott was ist purer ein neuer
schreibst schleim saugrüssel freund ist
da drückst du ihn ganz fest kann der
bunte schleier aufsaugen und wieder
ausspucken wir treffen hier alles also
das auch gar nicht das tue ich hier
jetzt mach ich dir so leicht die chance
doch rein
ich weiß nicht wie das funktionieren
sollte nikolaus kirche
hier sind dieses leiden im grün metallic
nummer acht magix la ola change aber
stimmt es dass sollen sich in bloss
schleim verwandeln
warum machen sie mal hier können die
doch so eine winter edition daraus
machen wir machen die bitte da nicht so
ein weihnachtslied edition ist voller
schleim ich sehe aber kein farbwechsel
deswegen
ein bisschen boring ja wie auch bei dem
ersten keine ahnung warum die farbe sich
nicht was ich falsch mache ihr könnt mir
gerne sagen ich glaube ich lernen
langsam wie man mit schleim spielt
wahrscheinlich muss man einfach drei
stunden damit spielen bisschen farbe
sich wechselt jedes mal sehr gut was
können sie noch so großartiges anbieten
um auch in vielen farben einfach ali
wollen wieder hier ist es viel machen
und perlen rein wenn wir natürlich
sofort ausprobieren
wir bitten mich wieder an auf den boden
fallen dann einmal verrühren und hier
sehen sie schleim mit perlen drauf und
intoniert
das erinnert mich jetzt hier ein
bisschen an mir jungfrauen schleim
[Musik]
verdient hier nochmal sehen
sie erzeuge lustige geräusche indem du
den neuesten mit den fingern in die
dürren rage wenn mein bruder dieses
video sieht wird er mich auslachen
das sei die bereit seid ihr bereit für
pox geräusche der markt wuchs geräusche
oder mango sollen wir hier sitzen
das war ein echter fuchs
und ja das ist einfach mein
lieblingsland aber der ist anders von
der konsistenz oh mein gott ist der teil
der ist perfekt weil der ist nicht so
streibich schleimig sondern so fester
bub sei müsse bestes leim
das ist auch der perfekte stress
ballmann so ein telefonat selbst oder
seine hausaufgaben macht oder keine
ahnung vom fernsehen sich gestresst
fühlt einfach da draufdrücken und wenn
man einmal ein bisschen lachen möchte
weil das leben einfach nichts zum lachen
bietet perfekt mal gucken was die nummer
elf zu bieten hat was gibt es dazu ich
muss ich bin so viel check your content
damit machen wollen die auch machen das
ist dann halt diese stylistin hier
wieder diese kleinen perlen und das
müsste man dann zusammen und dann dann
gesagt hast der bub sein ist mein
lieblingsland sind bei der hälfte
angekommen
ich halte den schimmernden magix la
galaxy in deinen händen mixe neue
galaxie mit neuen farben und nimmt sie
überall mit hin
[Musik]
so schaut's euch mein galaxy ball an
hier kann zu fremde galaxien sehen der
ist so schön ich habe die galaxien
meinen händen aber mischt man das nicht
gleich zusammen dann ist es einfach
zusammen oder verbinden sich die farben
nicht so nein sie werden immer ja also
das ist einfach das sieht so hochgradig
giftig aus aber es macht echt spaß
mittlerweile jetzt verstehe ich den halb
zurück in mein galaxy ball ja das ist
das mein galaxy ball sehr gute halbzeit
pause nicht wundern ich habe mir gerade
meine haare hochgesteckt weil ich es war
mir zu viele locken im gesicht war ein
experiment und das ist ein bisschen
gescheitert ich bin ehrlich mit euch und
ich will mich mehr auf meine
adventskalender als auf meine haare
konzentrieren deswegen machen wir weiter
türchen nummer 13 ich mein was kommt
jetzt noch es werden noch weitere slime
zu kommen aber ich erwarte noch so ein
klein noch so überraschend wie das
cuxland auf diesem niveau bräuchten noch
ein magic slim neon und noch einmal
diese weichen kern
ist das wieder ein farbwechsel dass lime
bringe deine magix lange im dunkeln zum
leuchten lade den magix leyen im
tageslicht auf damit er im dunkeln
seine leuchtkraft bekommt das kann doch
nicht gesund sein also hier haben wir
unseren globalen bedarf aber der muss
jetzt ins tageslicht kann er sich auf
läuft auch aufladen 15
welche das ist metallic totale geld
nummer 16
wirklich stelle mithilfe deines
reagenzglas dass ihr neues line
kreationen her hängen sie an deinen
schluss land für über damit du auch in
der schule mit einem slam spielen kannst
das wird mein neuer schlüsselanhänger
irgendwie feier ist es die hände ist
schleim haltbar eine frage an die
experten da draußen schreibt man bitte
in die kommentare wie lange so ein
schwein haltbar wie oft kann man damit
spielend wann sollte ich ihn
wegschmeißen in was für eine mülltonne
schmeißt man ihn in den restmüll
vielleicht sieht sie das haben wir noch
nicht einmal einen adventskalender
auszupacken denn nicht mit getränken
essen oder beauty zu tun hat hier ist
leon rot und hier auch gewitter das kann
ich nicht einfach so machen dass kinder
landet überall also oder beziehungsweise
wir wissen was passiert mit tik tok ich
glaube ich werde ein paar tipps damit
machen ich habe ich noch ein paar tricks
ein neuer golfer an der schlei mogens
deine sammlung schleim sammlung
diese heimliche liebe gold ich weiß
nicht wo das ist mein neuer
lieblingsname wenn man so was wie ein
lieblings schleim haben kann dann ist
das meine wenn ihr an diesem punkt nicht
neidisch auf mich sein stimmt irgendwas
mit euch nicht ich weiß ich muss es
einmal erwähnen wer denkt auch an den
film fly aber die ganze zeit schon so
slime trinkt sagt ihr von meinem neuen
schleim ring eher guten goll deutschland
20 natürlich noch ein coup slime ich bin
ja jetzt experten auf diesem gebiet das
ist ein pups leim den erkenne ich von
drei kilometern weiterhin ausfallen
sie sind wieder diese papier perlen und
der festere bub sei man kennt und 22
hier haben wir augen und blauen schleim
let's do it toller blauer schleier wie
man ihn kennt jetzt kommen die augen
es passt man zu halloween bruder
verschiedenen größen
so lassen super beschwören bringt ein
slime zum leben mit ein paar augen drauf
[Musik]
hat es nur verstörend immer aus wie so
ein reagenzglas monster
[Musik]
da steht super safe drauf das ist super
safe wirklich denn kinder werden daran
kein krebs bekommt der wechsel von wila
zu kriegen oder pink und lila
er wechselt auch eigentlich die farbe
aber wie wir wissen ich krieg mich und
jetzt sind wir da weihnachten das 24
türchen das beste team von allen und was
drin
okay wir haben durchgezogenen nikolaus
und an weihnachten das ist ja auch wenn
man ein schwein hier mit gleichen golden
kommenden schaffst du doch ihr wollt es
doch alle sehen oder aber das ding da
reinzukriegen es wirklich eine kunst her
leute wie beendet man so ein video es
war hier alles drin die möglichkeiten
sind wirklich endlos würde sagen das ist
ein toller adventskalender ich empfehle
den weiter wenn meine nicht nur nerven
den wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle hier
gesehen hätten
dann haben sie sich angeschaut dann
würde ich mir echt überlegen diesen
adventskalender kindern zu schenken weil
das ist ja irgendwie total süß und
bisschen verstörend aber ansonsten wie
günstig wir sehen uns das nächste machen
ich habe wieder gefallen
und wenn dem so ist dann zeigt mit dem
daumen nach oben und rechts des
kalenders soll ich noch testen bei
müller haben sie wirklich viele
verschiedene adventskalender und ich hab
ich viele mitgenommen und war gestern
natürlich meinen tik tok slime content
in findet ihr bestimmt ist er schon
online
ich werde jetzt loslegen ich mache jetzt
tape talks schleim content ganz ehrlich
leute in diesem punkt meine karriere
kann
mir das auch erlauben nicht so ist dann
tschüss
[Musik]